hi my name is jermaine rawlings and
here's the story of how my grandmother's
macaroni and cheese got me on tv
[Music]
i'm a self-taught private chef and i own
and operate a company called frat boy
cuisines i never thought i was going to
be a chef somehow i just fell into this
i'm originally from maryland i grew up
in a family where literally everyone in
the house cooks i went to college at boo
state university upon graduating i
commissioned as an officer in the united
states air force and i managed to get
stationed out in los angeles air force
base moving out to la and being so far
away from my family i really missed the
food specifically my grandmother's
macaroni and cheese man this is one
thing that i just always remember
growing up we'd have it on special
occasions holidays when i was a kid i
probably put on about 20 pounds because
of grams
all that good food she would make us it
really really sticks to your ribs seeing
as though i didn't want to have to fly
all the way back to maryland i gave her
a phone call and luckily she was willing
to give me the recipe the thing that
makes my grandmother's macaroni and
cheese different from say what you get
from a restaurant or some other places
is the texture it's not too loose but
it's not too stiff she has those crispy
edges around the outside that everyone
fights for all that wrapped into one
dish just really really takes things to
a next level i taught myself how to make
it and i felt like i really accomplished
something i felt like i was at home i
could get something that i knew and love
whenever i wanted to i figured i could i
could pretty much do anything from there
i started venturing out and trying other
things being stationed out here you run
into a lot of people in the military who
don't have a place to go for like
thanksgiving and me just loving to be
around my family i can understand how
that could be something that's difficult
for somebody to be alone for the
holidays living in l.a i just started
hosting a friend's giving every year
it's good to get people together they're
going to eat they're going to drink
everybody's happy at thanksgiving when i
had all my friends over the macaroni and
cheese was always a hit so from there
i'm like well hey let's start throwing
more parties something that got really
big were caribbean nights and in my
caribbean nights i specifically would
make this curry chicken good curry
chicken will just hug you it's so
comforting it's so warming it really
makes you feel at home and just makes
you feel good so now we'll call it no
hurry curry chicken i realized i had a
little ego i'm like all right so this is
my thing now
after i got out the air force i enrolled
in usc into a program called the mbv
program they want to teach people how to
you know start a business halfway
through attending grad school is when i
auditioned for the show masterchef i was
this close to making it on the show but
i didn't make it i realized that maybe i
do have a talent it was my passion i
enjoyed doing it from there frat boy
cuisines was born and master chef wasn't
the last chance i had to be on a cooking
show one day my friend reached out to me
on facebook and said i should try out
for the show on food network called
tailgate battles tailgate battles are
the show where they take the ultimate
tailgaters and have them compete against
each other i took my grandmother's
macaroni and cheese
and then i added jerk chicken with a
mango habanero sauce on there i thought
that it would really really ride the
judges one of the judges actually has a
caribbean food truck so when he came
there he was like oh man you really want
to give me a jerk chicken when this is
what i do and they really really loved
it yo grandma taught you right this mac
and cheese is on point the competition
was tough and i made it to the top three
i didn't win that one but hey they were
definitely thoroughly impressed in the
dish i prepared my grandmother was super
excited that i used her macaroni and
cheese and she was really really really
happy really proud my goal is to open up
my own restaurant where it has a lot of
finger foods a great vibe something that
people can really enjoy i don't know
what the future holds but i do know i
love cooking and i'm going to see how
far that takes me
[Music]
you